what do cows Rams and giraffes have in
common their bony headgear from curly
horns to pronghorns branching antlers to
knobby ossicones all these mammals have
elaborate bones growing out of their
heads kind of strange when you think
about it
[Music]
scientists thought it was strange too so
they took a closer look at how these
crowning glories grow they found that
when horns or antlers start to grow many
of the genes used to create nerve skin
and bone during early development were
switched on the fact that the process
was similar in horns and antlers suggest
that animals with bony head growths all
descend from a common ancestor but
antlers grow back year after year unlike
our infants most mammals can't grow
something like a limb on demand antlers
aren't simply bone they're covered in
skin and laced with delicate nerves and
they grow really fast
we're talking 30 kilograms of antler in
less than a year this fast complicated
tissue growth that regenerates year
after year has caught the attention of
tissue engineers people looking to
regrow human limbs when scientists
examined ear during the antler growing
season they found an unusual set of
genes come to life some of the genes
turned on in a cell destined to become
an antler are associated with cancers in
humans but these beasts don't have a
higher rate of cancer in fact servants
like deer are five times less likely to
get cancer than other mammals this
suggests they found a way to control
otherwise dangerous cancer pathways
harnessing fast growth without the
out-of-control proliferation of cancer
cells exploring these genes may help
scientists understand cancer growth in
the future particularly bone cancers
like osteo carcinoma and tissue
engineers can also look at these
processes to further understand how to
prosthesis or one day regrow limbs this
is just antlers
who knows what horns may have to offer
you may never look at the cud chewing
horn sporting cow the same way again
[Music]